- You may have been
rejected by your family
because you're LGBT,
so our Thanksgiving celebration
is a way to celebrate
our family that we've
built here at the center
and for everyone to have the opportunity
to be supported during the holidays.
- I'm Nico Tortorella.
I'm an actor, an activist,
and a firm believer
that our differences
actually make us stronger.
I'm on a journey with
IKEA to meet real people
and discover the diverse
and spectacular ways
they celebrate the holidays.
Maybe you celebrate Thanksgiving
with your extended family
and maybe you celebrate Thanksgiving
with your chosen family, like
the people at our first stop.
- I'm David Mariner, and
I'm the Executive Director
of The DC Center for the LGBT Community.
Welcome to our Fifth Annual
Thanksgiving Celebration.
Everyone comes with their own experiences
and traditions and customs.
We need to acknowledge not
just their LGBT identities,
but their whole self.
- My name is Nikilas Mawanda.
I'm originally from Uganda
but right now living in Washington, D.C.
- [Nico] The DC Center
helps LGBTQ+ asylum seekers
and refugees who are no longer
safe in their own countries.
- It's commonplace for
someone to be kicked
out of their home in Uganda for LGBT.
It's commonplace for someone
to be disowned by their family.
- [Nico] This year the
asylum seekers and refugees
are bringing a traditional
dish from their home country
to share with the entire center.
Nik is preparing rolexes.
It's called rolex in Uganda, too?
- Yes, and it's just the way we roll it.
- Ahh.
- It is really important
for me that I share
the beautiful thing about my culture.
We celebrate brotherhood,
sisterhood, in forms of sharing.
- Knife is on the inside or the outside?
- Knife is on the inside.
- OK.
- Hi everyone, I'm Tamara.
My pronouns are she, her, and hers.
My tradition actually has
been coming to the DC Center
to volunteer and give back.
- [Nico] I think when we go
around the table and we share
the traditions that we
have around the holidays,
we all are a little bit more connected
and we understand how similar we all are.
- My favorite holiday tradition is eating.
(group laughing)
And second only by being
around my friends and family.
- I grew up in Nebraska, and we always had
a Thanksgiving dinner like,
not too different than this.
- [Nik] I would love to share
the good things about my tradition.
People won't learn unless you share,
it's part of bringing cross-cultures.
It's part of learning about each other,
appreciating each other.
- [Nico] We celebrate differently,
but maybe that's what
makes us all so beautiful.
It's more important today
than ever to show up
for the holidays as yourself.
Share your tradition, 'cause
the more that we see,
the more we believe, the more we respect,
and the more we love.